nancy pelosi everyone's favorite
politician the best trader in all of
washington dc last friday in london
stated that capitalism quote has not
served the u.s economy as it as well as
it should
excuse me she's worth over 100 million
dollars she's the biggest capitalist
probably in all of politics and so
really confusing now her point is that
there has been a gradual shift in recent
decades from the concept of stakeholder
capitalism which allowed wages for both
executives and workers to rise based on
productivity so the executives and the
workers their well their wages both
increased together as productivity went
up that's stakeholder capitalism but she
says that we have shifted to more of a
shareholder capitalism where executive
compensation has outpaced wage growth
for workers and so naturally the
politician who is worth over 100 million
dollars points to capitalism and says
it's not working as it should
really really really crazy now this is
all
while
the government is trying to push through
a 3.5 trillion dollar budget
reconciliation bill and it is planning
to fund the legislation through tax
increases on corporations and wealthy so
if you want to increase taxes and take
money from the wealthier from
corporations the best thing possible to
do is go convince the american people
that capitalism doesn't work the
capitalists are the bad people we should
yell and scream at them and we should
take all their money well i tend to
think that rather than condemning
success we should take what the wealthy
what the corporations what the
entrepreneurs what the investors know
and we should
identify what the actual problem is if
you go to the first principles thinking
on this it is not a wealth problem it is
an education problem and if we simply
were able to educate the bottom 50
percent of americans and said
stop saving dollars the dollar is
guaranteed to go down in value
asset owners people who own stocks real
estate crypto commodities etc they have
drastically pulled ahead because we as
the politicians are going to continue to
devalue your currency nobody is telling
them that
nobody is saying hey rather than
spending all of our effort trying to
take money from the wealthy instead what
we should do is we should teach people
how to fish don't give somebody the fish
teach them how to fish how do you do
that through financial education
personal finance now when we start to
get into this uh there's a lot in here
but what i want to explicitly call out
is first here is exactly what she said
this is a direct quote
in america capitalism is our system it
is our economic system but it has not
served our economy as well as it should
so what we want to do is not depart from
that but to improve it and to make sure
that it serves us well that is very easy
to say when you are worth more than 100
million dollars now on top of that
america is the most prosperous country
in the world it's the most innovative it
is still the light house on the hill for
anyone in the world regardless of where
you come from who you are what your
wealth your education level is what
color your skin is what religion
anything it does not matter you can come
to america and you can build a life of
wealth happiness and financial security
how can you do that well because we have
a capitalistic system social mobility is
possible here you can come here with
nothing and build a life of something
that is not true in most countries in
the world but the problem is when we
look at these charts we have two charts
first we're going to show that
everyone likes to point at these charts
say here's the problem this is the share
of gross domestic income so the
compensation of employees that are paid
wage and salary
it's going down the capital siphoned 50
trillion dollars from workers from 1975
to 2018. it's very clear that the
percent that goes to the employees is
going down okay everyone agrees i don't
think anyone is arguing that this data
is inaccurate so we see that downward
trend they drew the nice little red line
there so everyone can see going down got
it now the next one the top point one
percent now own more than the bottom
eighty percent again people get really
really upset with this if you look at
this chart here you can see that the top
one percent absolutely
banging top one percent is just accruing
assets like you've never seen before the
top point one percent banging they keep
accruing assets as well but the bottom
eighty percent has been going down the
ownership of wealth of the bottom eighty
percent keeps falling off a cliff now
you can point to capitalism and say
capitalism is bad but we had capitalism
before the 70s
capitalistic society was here
what the hell happened
well maybe it's not capitalism
nancy pelosi i appreciate you bringing
this up because it's a really important
point the 70s are a really important
time to look at there's even a website
it's called what the
wtf happened in 1971. well in 1971 we
decided to go off of the gold standard
we created fiat currency that's what
happened this is a perfect example here
productivity continued to rise at almost
the exact same rate as it did beforehand
but compensation total compensation
went flat
it went flat this is not a top one
percent bottom one percent eighty
percent twenty percent any percent
compensation in general for everyone
went flat while productivity continued
to rise right after we unpegged the
dollar from gold so next is we've got a
chart here that is going to show the
income gains widely shared in the
decades it didn't matter before 1971 it
did not matter if you were wealthy or
not wealthy the income gains were shared
so this is the real family income
between 1947 and 2016.
but all of a sudden what happened is if
you were in the 95th percentile
you ended up making way more money look
at the 95th percentile the people who
hold assets the people who are rich who
understand who are educated
the train kept going nothing stopped for
them
they continued to hold assets and they
continued to grow
at the exact same rate that they were
but the median and the bottom 20 percent
of americans they went sideways why
because they were told save dollars save
save save save your way to financial
security and what we did is we unpegged
the commodity underneath the currency
and we absolutely decimated that
currency where it has lost a significant
portion of its purchasing power and what
we literally did was that one decision
pushed the bottom 20 percent of people
sideways while everyone continued to go
that was wealthy continued on the exact
same rate then we've got this chart that
this this is the craziest one that by
far is the craziest one you want to
point to what happened how about this
one if you look at this chart right here
in 1970 the top one percent of earners
they ain't got [ __ ] compared to
everybody else nothing
the bottom 90 of earners are all the way
up there at 200 percent
income growth the top 1
before 1970 they were negative they were
negative
we just crossed over into positive
territory for the top one percent of
earners in 1970
and then all of a sudden what happened
we went
sideways
just sideways for that top or for the
bottom 90
and the top one percent exploded since
1971.
and so what you end up finding is this
is not a capitalism problem it's a
currency devaluation problem we still
have 45 percent of americans who own no
investable assets they simply hold
dollars and we are constantly devaluing
that currency and they have no clue
that they are actually worse off today
than they were previously and so this is
not a capitalism problem it is a
currency devaluation problem and so
therefore i appreciate nancy pelosi who
is worth over 100 million dollars saying
that capitalism is not accomplishing or
hasn't served us well but i think
actually the problem is that monetary
and fiscal policy hasn't served us well
and capitalism happens to be the one
that gets the bad rap but it's not a
capitalism problem we maybe should stop
devaluing our currency at historic rates
because it is simply punishing the
bottom 45 of americans at an
unprecedented rate
couldn't agree more
i actually generally agree with what
she's talking about how the shift has
changed from um productivity and both uh
employees wages increasing right but
inflation's hurting the bottom fifty
percent of americans way more than it
hurts the top ten top one percent um and
look education is the answer right no uh
thirty three percent of millionaires
never made over a hundred thousand
dollars a year right it's it's a money
management system it's how you can grow
your wealth how to get in assets that i
actually appreciate and i i think her
heart's in the right place with what
she's saying but it's really hard to
take it um
you gotta take it with a grain of salt
when she's estimated to be worth 114
million dollars can i make a wild
statement i think you understand
economics better than she does i think
you understand what the driver of wealth
inequality is better than she does
because i i agree with you i think she
actually believes capitalism has not
served us well i
again maybe there's people who are out
there that are bad i think for the
majority of people they're trying to do
the right thing with the information
they have i think she really believes
this i think you understand much better
than she does what drives wealth
inequality and also how to fix it it's
not to attack capitalism it's not to
change the capitalistic system it's not
to evolve it in some weird way instead
it is to simply stop debating hey guys
bang bang thanks so much for watching
the best business show today and don't
forget to check out our partner sofi
they make all this possible they're a
super app that lets you save spend
borrow earn and invest all from one
single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account
sofi.compomp and make sure you come back
and watch more of the best business show
we're going gonna build the biggest
business show in the world and we need
your help
[Music]